hi I'm Donna Oh that is the perfect name
for you I love it never change it wasn't
gonna your Craig right oh yes I hate
that name so boring
sound like someone's cousin Craig Craig
want to be a Spanish man named Terrence
but that didn't happen okay so here's my
list of duties I'm basically the office
manager how about you oh I did
everything everything I carried the
Eagleton Department on my shoulders for
years and I loved every second of it you
don't even know I guess we can make a
switch to Bermuda grass it's only 80
cents more per square foot what gimme
gimme gimme you want me to put Bermuda
grass in a continental climate that's a
six on the Beaufort scale in a park with
zero drainage I want Kentucky bluegrass
I want a 10% discount and I want you to
apologize to my best friend Donna yeah
hi is there and I'm just guessing here's
some kind of medication that you maybe
need a lot of and I've taken none of or
maybe too much out today oh I have I
have a medical condition all right it's
called caring too much and it's in
terrible also I have eczema see this is
Craig oh no that is insane I will burn
this place to the ground if you picked
that one okay good choice
God you play guitar no that's a super
small piano okay I'm gonna need the
sarcasm to take a long walk right now my
terrible nephew Sebastian is having a
sixth birthday party this weekend and
the clown they hired has shingles you
think your band could play for an hour
how much 75 75 thousand dollars how
about three hundred three 150 they'll do
it ah thank you
that is such a relief I'd love my nephew
very much but he's a horrible little
tyrant so don't ruin this day for him no
don't do that I don't like this game I
don't know what the rules are okay the
people in this room are the first
members of the pawnee-eagleton youth
committee now April says that young
people think the word committee is lame
so let's just think of this as like a
super chill funny hangout worse that's
worse okay new people let's introduce
ourselves craig middlebrooks Samantha in
the boardroom Miranda
bedroom I know it's not ideal but it's
Who I am this is my friend Madison she's
amazing and she drove me here okay youth
committee update on the unity concert
Madison so far 12 bands have said yes
and we asked them all to submit a song
for the new town anthem contest I think
we should book Orrin as a headliner I
think it's a no-brainer
he dislocates his shoulder to the music
of Billy Joel the Pawnee Journal called
it why would anyone do this stop
suggesting Orrin Craig any update on the
art tents 14 local artists have signed
up to show their work it was going to be
15 but then this one guy described
himself as Jackson Pollock esque and I
told him that's finger painting for
adults and I hate that you had the
world's most adorable baby and I love
you you are so freaking precious Leslie
knope's little stunt put three people in
the hospital this bee incident is just
the latest assault coming from the
Pawnee side of this murder Mike
Patterson is Eagleton's most tenacious
reporter when he sinks his teeth into
something he's like a dog with a bone oh
my god you can't lean in to whisper and
then yell that's not fair this merger is
so fragile everyone is on edge and no
one is talking about the unity concert
why would anybody think that was a prank
so sad people believe anything it was a
prank though right no more press okay
you just have to lay low for awhile I
promise it'll all blow over April your
competence and your level-headedness is
very moving to me and I will follow your
advice right after I go to the hospital
and apologize to every victim in person
fine but no cameras fine I won't bring
in I can't handle all this fighting it's
like Thanksgiving 2004 all over again
don't even have somebody follow me I'm
distraught what's wrong with you you
look like Meryl Streep at the end of
iron weed you wish well I've been
driving all over Indiana looking for
bands to play the unity concert I got
nothing to show for it except for four
car accidents all these strangers
insurance information oh I get it you
have car insurance
why don't you brag about it hey you're
from Eagleton right are there any places
out there I should check out I used to
go see live shows at Patterson's but I'm
boycotting until the owner apologizes
for what she said to me at the dog park
anything else I hear cozies bar gets
pretty packed on Thursdays but I've
never been because it's mostly
middle-aged women and I'm allergic to
turkey neck really that's the best part
we should split a turkey sometime Donna
April Wine Country train is leaving the
station you ready I want to come I love
wine and everything about it the soil
the vines
I studied botany for three years at
Purdue University don't Boilermakers
there will be alcohol there so I will go
as well
maybe I'll tag along I don't have any
more work to do maybe it'll be a
relaxing I invite any of you I start
with two cool people I ended up with a
bunch of grandpas wasn't grandpa's week
at the vineyard any a lot of fancy
people there please I beg you don't
embarrass me how would we embarrass you
you're already doing it I begged you
April Ludgate professional drinker where
did you study miss lead gates the wine
Academy the wine Academy in Bordeaux yes
Karel make sure she's in Group A excuse
me I want in too I know I don't look at
the part but I know everything about
wine and I will prove it
my name is craig middlebrooks and this
is my deborah rewards card
pumpkin undertones of lavender medium
plus body it's mostly pumpkin there's so
much pumpkin it's like a Charlie Brown
Halloween special I'm getting notes of
dried Robins blood old dirty cashews and
just a hint of a robot's bathwater an
old-world wine Italian it's a bit d
Kyoto classical 2010 it's new world
Northern California Napa Valley
someplace beautiful and warm and amazing
where everyone is in great shape and the
night sky is both stars this comes from
your mothers but with a filet mignon I'd
recommend a red of something bold and
dry like David Sedaris perhaps you could
recommend a Riesling instead what if
you're eating steak you loon well good
night everyone
I'm going to go home and feel totally
fine Who am I kidding I'm gonna go home
put on a Macy Gray album and cry in the
mirror
why are you bummed are you all blind I
want that job at Toms Bistro I've been
trying to show you for the last five
hours look man you know your stuff but
you're like a crazy volcano you have to
show me you can bring it down a notch Oh
bring it down a thousand knots as if I
have to good evening may I assist you
with a wine tonight yeah I'm having fish
so maybe a full-bodied red you know sir
you might want to consider something
white to go with your fish no red and
break some ice cubes I like ice cubes in
my red wine hmm I'll have a glass of
your most expensive red wine mixed with
a glass of your cheapest white wine
served in a dog bowl silly straws all
around please I'll be right back with my
recommendations seems to be keeping it
together for you sir a light crispy no
with just a hint of lemon to bring out
the flavors in your fish I brought you a
bowl Cabernet which should still taste
okay when watered down and for you madam
would you consider this Rose a it's
halfway between red and white
thanks very much enjoy think I may have
found my new somolia ought to make sure
the wine cellar Tom's Bistro is
soundproof what is this mess why are you
all in my office I am calm I am grateful
I am Craig we're on one last mission to
help the people of Pawnee Craig can you
sign the requisition form and speed
things up you know Craig when I first
met you I thought there's a man who
loves his job and then I thought oh wow
he's intense and then I thought oh no
he's insane that person is psychotic and
I need to call the police yeah that's
usually the way it goes but I just think
you've come so far and I'm so glad that
we are leaving the parks department in
your hands
funny though it's true
those silly things you do they only
bring me closer to you
[Music]
my name is craig middlebrooks i'm the
part-time sommelier here at Tom's Bistro
and I'm a very good singer nice cruising
buddy
the gentleman over by the bar there sent
you over this glass of wine and his
business card okay okay fine we are
gathered here today to join Craig
Middlebrooks and Tydfil Montalban in
holy matrimony I don't know about this
I'm very scared I'll just relax you
nervous Nelly you're right we love each
other and the tax break is substantial
well the best man please present the
Rings good luck you two
typhoon my love happy anniversary
do you have any regrets not one not a
single one do you have any regrets are
you kidding
thousands most recently this trap
you